dùng đột biên giới giữa thái lan và các buồn chia từ tháng 2.000 thức trập hay lâm đã kiến
ngày dù lịch hai nước dưới vào tình trạng khó khăn. Như khách sản và nhà hàng tại
cu vực đồng bắt thay lan cần biên giới phải nống cờ.
Tại các buồn chia, lượng khách cuộc tế tới các cu vực phía bác giảm tới
mấy mươi phần chăm trong tháng bài, người tổn thất lớn trong ngày dù lịch.
Biac đống cờ các cờ khổ làm giảnh đoạn các quyến dù lịch qua lại biên giới,
anh hưởng đến những đẹp đổi tiếng như số chang.
Một số cúch ra đã quyến cáo công dân cần nhắc khi đến 2 nước, khiến các công ty lượng
hành và điều chính tuo đề đàn bảo an toàn cho khách.
Dù tổn cúch giúp lịch thái lan khẳng định hoạt động giúp lịch vẫn sĩnh giảm bình thường,
tâm lý lông hại về ăning vẫn khiến sòng bố lợt thử nước ngoài vào ngành giúp lịch và dịch vụ giảm đáng kể.
Tình yên việc hai bên đặt được phỏ thận lương bán lực tức và vô điều kiện,
có hiểu lực tựa hai mê bốn dựa ngày 2,3 táng bài hai nhìn không chăm hay lâm.
Sống cuộc khỏi đam diễn ra với vai trọng chúng ra in hoa dài của Malaysia,
đăng mở ra có hộ chấm rất xung đột.
Xin mì, tích cập này được khi bảo sẽ giúp ông định hình,
khóa phục hoạt động, rù lịch và thức bước nước kinh tế,
vĩ xin kế quảng người dân hai nước chở lại quy đạo bình thường.